but right now i want to introduce uh
our guests for a little fireside chat uh
it's gonna be about 20 minutes long and
as we're talking a few minutes in if you
have any questions or anything make your
way down here uh and you could ping your
question to or tell eric your question
he'll grab our attention and we'll go
from there but uh i want to introduce
the founder of tickle and branch out
rick mourini
all right what's happening
so i get to be the only thing between
all these people and beers right that's
right no pressure
so
rick's been kind enough to join us but i
emailed them um about uh
in june and when he said yes i was just
so pumped and so happy to have him so we
agreed to do this little chat so uh
so let's just begin with a little bit of
your background who are you why are you
cool
um
how about who am i not why am i cool
um so let's see so i'm rick mourini i uh
let's see i grew up in a small town in
new hampshire i've been a tech
entrepreneur out in silicon valley for
the last 15 years
undergrad was unh back in new hampshire
then started to work for a company
called fisher scientific doing corp dev
corporate finance not technical kind of
stuff that we do out here and then went
to harvard business school and got my
mba there and that really changed my
life because i met my co-founder of my
first company there a guy named james
currier and james and i um at hbs took
the myers-briggs test along with
everyone and that sparked the idea for
our first company which was called
tickle.com tickle was the largest
personality testing site on the web and
uh it actually became the 18th largest
site in the world at one point and we
started that company back in cambridge
and moved it out to san francisco back
in 2000
and grew that company to uh to 100
million dollar exit back in 04 stuck
around there for a couple years and uh
with an earn out with monster started my
second company super fan which built
facebook apps and social games kind of a
digital agency
for brands like cbs and universal and
sony and others and then had the idea
for branch out so pivoted the team over
to doing branch out and branch out at
this point has over 800 million profiles
so that's
grown into a big site and other than
that i've also done a lot of angel
investing i'm in over 40 angel
investments and advisory rules now
so just for the record i just realized
this we did not plan this uh our outfits
just wanted to get that out there i
i just realized this is very similar yes
great minds think of like i think
same socks
yeah no hopefully hopefully not close
okay
if only i had the uh the patrick dempsey
haircut we would just
uh
so
i don't know if that's good or bad but
go ahead and move on oh it's good uh so
before we uh before we we were hanging
out a couple weeks ago and uh we're
we're chatting and you said that when
you started tickle uh you wanted to you
had you had two goals you said you're
not going to quit unless you either went
public or sold it for 100 million
dollars and when you think about it for
a quiz company i mean that's like that's
mind-blowing like who on earth would
think that most people would never think
that's even possible what made you think
that was possible i mean did you have
market validation was it a gut feeling i
mean what made you why you were crazy
why did you think that
so it was more gut feeling um there was
no magic around that number it just felt
like a big round number that two guys
from small town new hampshire could
strive to get there you know a billion
dollars sounds too unattainable um but
100 million sounded like hey if the
stars align and we work hard maybe we
get there and um
you know
when when you've got a successful
company you know your goal is always
going to be to to go public right every
entrepreneur wants to start a company
and go public and and one of the lessons
there is um you've got to know when to
sell and and when to uh to hold and keep
going and i think a good example of that
is mark cuban who started broadcast.com
he was very smart to sell to yahoo for
5.7 billion dollars back in the day and
then mark zuckerberg was very smart not
to sell to yahoo for a billion and keep
going and now facebook is worth almost
200 billion so um so yeah i think the
lesson there is you've got to know when
the right time is to sell and um and for
us we had seven different offers uh for
for tickle and um the seventh one is
finally the one that got us to 100
million which we can we can go back to
later but um but once we got to that
number it felt right which which was way
different than what joel was talking
about earlier he was talking about lean
lean method methodology and validating
and market validation but for you it was
just
a gut feeling almost
it was a gut feeling it was a goal um
you know you want to set high yet
attainable goals and we got there
but you know there was also
when you're in a position like that
where you can you can see the future um
and you you understand your business
better than anyone else of course
when you've got a high probability of
success the way that i think mark
zuckerberg saw his business going
that's when you don't sell when you
don't see a very clear path to be able
to get to the next level that's when you
sit back and you say maybe i should lock
in some money now and especially you
know coming from you know i didn't come
from money so when you have the chance
to do that put some money away um which
you know it can be rainy day money so
you can go take some bigger chances
later
i think that makes a lot of sense when
you don't see a clear path to getting to
the billion dollars
all right
so since tickle you've done super fan
you've done branch out and now you're an
investor i mean you've done a bunch of
different companies
when you are starting out
how do you judge between going after
something that you're extremely
passionate about versus something that
is very clear that it's an opportunity
to make a lot of money how do you
balance that because it seems like
something that everyone struggles with
so i think any entrepreneur starting a
company should probably write down the
five or ten things that motivate them
and
financial return should probably be one
of the five but hopefully not number one
and following your passion because you
love a certain space should also be top
five definitely top ten but maybe also
not number one
you know a lot of people like me love
sports or music and would love to build
sites around that the reality for most
is that it's really hard to be able to
attract a lot of money into that from
venture capitalists as well as to be
able to build it up and get a lot of
traction because there's a ton of
competition
and hard to have a big exit right so
when you start to raise money you've got
to be realistic about do i have an idea
that goes beyond my personal passion is
this an idea that can get vcs or angels
really excited and not just get me
excited but get you know the entire
ecosystem behind this you've got to hire
people that would be potentially leaving
their jobs leaving their high paying
jobs that pay their bills and support
their families to also come on board
with you
which again your passion needs to
translate beyond just what you're into
and be able to support bringing
investors in bringing other employees in
and being able to give a good return
so it's not just about the financial
return
it's not just about the passion you want
to bring all those together
to be able to to do something that gets
you excited every day and i don't just
mean i want to do a music site because i
love music getting excited i'm an
entrepreneur
that has started a couple different
companies and they weren't my like
passion like online personality tests
with tickle wasn't like my passion and
with branch out career networking
recruiting on facebook isn't my passion
what is my passion is the ability to
create companies that touch the lives of
hundreds of millions of people so with
tickle we had 200 million registered
users with branch out we have over 800
million profiles
i would rather create companies that
have a positive impact on hundreds of
millions of lives than do a little niche
site music site um that is something
that i that i'm passionate about but
that's me and everyone's got to figure
out their you know their goals but if
you want to be realistic and attract
revenue
attract funding and be able to have a
big exit you've got to think about what
what's going to get me there and your
personal passion project may not
and by the way i also want to go back to
something earlier when i had said about
you know 100 million was was a good exit
i was happy but you could go for the
billion
a lot of people think that if they don't
get to that billion dollar exit right if
they're not the next whatsapp or or
snapchat or whatever that it's a fail
you know if you raise a small amount of
money especially angel money and you
sell your company for 5 million 10
million 20 million that's a big hit and
that changes your life in a big way as
long as you didn't raise too much money
where you still own a lot of the company
so you know if you guys are thinking
about starting companies or getting
involved early stage in a company
there's absolutely no shame in selling
for 10 20 30. i mean that's a big hit
silicon valley
is really focused on the billion dollar
exits a because it gets headlines and
and b because that's what the vcs need
to hit but for for most entrepreneurs
that billion dollar exit is never going
to come but being able to to lock in you
know x millions of dollars is life
life-changing and that's far more
important than getting you know
headlines and techcrunch
and by the way as we're chatting if
anyone has any questions we've got a mic
over here you can line up and we'll try
to call you call you so you can ask your
questions as we're chatting um but you
mentioned that you said there was five
things that mattered to you when
starting companies said passion and also
the financial gain are there
three other ones that you actually have
for you
um
i didn't bring my list with me but i'll
i'll kind of make some up so um i think
you know being
being a founder of a company one
really cool thing that you get to do is
you get to pick who you work with so for
me i like to hire people that are highly
intelligent people that have integrity
people who are entrepreneurial they roll
up their sleeves they they work hard
and people that are fun
so
that's who i like to work with that's
who i like to be and
and that's something that's important
running running companies i think um and
again you know i talked about being able
to change the world in a big way that's
something that that if i'm going to
spend my time you know some people say
if i could just change the life of one
person it's worth it it's not for me
because you know i think a lot of us
here in silicon valley are really lucky
we have the ability to touch millions of
lives i don't want to just help one
person i want to help you know 10
million 100 million people right
um and so i i if i are in the crowd
right now i'd be thinking well
it's easy for you you've had 100 million
dollar exit it's easy for you to say
these things well if you didn't have
that 100 million dollar exit
clearly you've started companies since
then how would you do it without that
cushion
let's say someone's out there
and they're broke let's say someone's an
employee they're having to work
part-time just to pay for their living
what would you what would you if you
were in those shoes what would you do
okay so i'll answer it as as an angel
investor um i've done 40 angel deals i
bet half of them are probably from um
serial entrepreneurs people have had an
exit and they want to do another one and
maybe it's their second or their third
company um guys like
travis and garrett at uber right so i've
been friends with those guys for 10
years they had done two successful
companies before and then they did uber
there's other guys that that um that
i've i've backed that are first-time
entrepreneurs i mean look at mark
zuckerberg i wish i was a backer in
facebook but look at him like he started
a company he was 18 years old right so
so it doesn't it doesn't matter that
you've you've been able to do it once
and then it's easy street after that the
reality is if you're a passionate person
if you've got a really interesting idea
if you can execute on that idea if you
have a good attitude an attitude goes a
long way i mean life to me is kind of 10
of what happens to you and 90 of how you
react to that right so if you have a
good attitude and you have all those
other
other things lined up you're going to be
able to attract great people around you
as well as investors people like me and
other angels and vcs
so there's there's absolutely a path to
being that next mark zuckerberg for
people like that and as a non-technical
guy um would you be following the the
lean methodology that joel was talking
about uh i mean
that wasn't exactly the case with tickle
but is that what you would do now
yeah so i mean it's a lot cheaper to
start companies now than it was back in
1999 when i did my first company
so
but one thing as a non-technical
founder you have to find your tech soul
mate and if you don't find them don't
bother trying to raise money if you're
in a tech company because the first
thing that the angel or the vc is going
to ask for is all right well you've i've
got i've got the idea i know what you're
going to do now i want to understand the
technology where's your cto let me talk
to him so you absolutely have to find
that technical soul mate when you're
starting a company
and that's something that you do now as
an angel i mean you're always absolutely
yeah i mean i mean even as a non-techie
i've been around this for 15 years so i
can ask enough of the right questions
and if i'm not hearing the right answers
like i don't you know i don't have a cto
i mean that's obviously a red flag all
right
do we have a a question we do have some
questions here
what's going on rick um i'm from boston
lived in new hampshire for a while so i
love me some kimball's orange pineapple
ice cream
uh so here's my question it's kind of
two part uh one
i would love to become to eventually
become an angel investor um so first
question is what would you say is the
minimum capital you need to become an
angel investor and the second question
is um
do i really need to go to business
school to to get there and i really mean
that neutrally
let me like what did you gain from
business school yeah that you wouldn't
have i'm gonna take the second one first
because it's a shorter answer
no you don't need to go back to business
school um it's a short answer i loved my
time at hbs um it was it was
life-changing literally it was a
life-changing experience because i
didn't go back into corporate finance
where i expected to go back
i met my co-founder and i became an
entrepreneur it changed my life now that
said i grew up in new hampshire i went
to undergrad new hampshire i went to b
school in boston i mean that was my life
there i wasn't out in silicon valley i
wasn't going to conferences like this i
wasn't going to network in events and
everything that everyone here has access
to
it could be a waste of two years of your
life
to go back and i'm a proponent of
education but you can educate yourself
here go work in a startup for two years
and learn a ton if especially if you
want to be a founder like what i always
tell people who want to be a founder is
um if if you've never been in a startup
you're you're jumping in too early go
work for a startup learn on someone
else's dime by the way if you go to hbs
it's going to cost you what i don't know
75 000 a year whatever it is instead
here you're getting paid 100 grand or
more or whatever it is to work and to
learn so so use that time here that's
the money that i saved up to potentially
be an angel investor okay good so now
you've got that saved up and now on the
angel question um angel investing is
highly highly risky right so whatever
your percentage of your portfolio that
you might allocate towards high risk
investments i mean like super high risk
maybe that's five percent of your
portfolio you should not be doing more
than five percent of your portfolio in
angel deals because you should expect
that many of those at least half of
those will be a zero and it's really
hard to make up when you have zeros
so
you know i mean start small um
especially with companies that you know
something about so for me as an angel
you know i always look for great teams
of course that's always number one i
look for big markets and disruptive
technologies um and that's really
important but third i tend to invest in
consumer internet and and mobile and
social and marketplaces things that i
know because of two reasons one i can
understand what they're doing and number
two i can be helpful so try to stick to
your your your area of expertise when
you're doing angel investing especially
early days i have more questions but
i'll be respectful maybe we can catch up
offline okay cheers
um
so
uh we kind of skipped over a a pretty
fun story and a pretty important part of
uh who you are which was the story of
tickle we kind of skipped over the part
of the 100 million dollar exit and when
we were chatting earlier you mentioned i
mean i was pretty amazed at it at what
happened obviously like i'm sure
everyone here is uh but you talked about
uh when you were with
monster.com bought it uh when you were
with them you
told me that getting there was 99
perspiration and one percent inspiration
and i think that's pretty wild because
really the odds are not in your favor to
have a hundred million dollar company so
how are you balancing the idea of
getting lucky versus working your ass
off and getting the the ability to even
negotiate that deal yeah so the word
lucky um so you guys have probably heard
um the harder i work the luckier i get
that is true
the other is you have to put yourself in
a position to be lucky and that's what
we did with um with the deal with
monster i mean we worked our butts off
um we started the company in 1999 we
sold it in 2004 so there's five years
there we raised money in march of 2000
march 6 of 2000 which was the day the
nasdaq tanked and the bubble burst
and that was not a fun time luckily we
got the money in before that happened
and moved out here and the first two
years were really really hard out here
because it was a recession i mean it was
you know silicon valley was impacted
more than any place else in the country
and it was just not not a fun place 2001
we were three months away from going
under i mean it was really scary our
bankers and lawyers were telling us you
should close up shop and you know pay
off your bills and we said that
we're not going to do that i mean we've
never lost in our lives and we're not
going to lose on this and does going
under even include your personal
what you have i mean your personal worth
yeah i mean everything was in in the
company so
going under means that you are you're
screwed yeah i mean big time so not just
a company but you yeah so we put like
everything into it and uh
yeah i think yeah yes yes yes um
this is hard yes it's uh so we put
everything into it and i started i
picked up the phone and started doing um
deals because our sales guys weren't
getting it done not because it was their
fault it's just nobody was buying ads
and in 2001 and um and one of the tests
that we had was an iq test this is a
very long answer to your question but
i'm gonna i'm gonna get to it it's a
good story um so
um i started picking up the phone and
doing um doing what's called cpa cost
per acquisition deals for our iq test
and um we would charge 15 for the test
and then we'd give five dollars to the
the company that the advertiser that
promoted it for us and it started taking
off and um and what happens is all these
guys look at each other and look at the
deals and they and then everyone started
calling me saying i want to run that i
want to run that and um and it took off
and in truth and that saved the company
and in 2011 we went from three months
away from bankruptcy and i'm sorry in
2001 in 2002
we won the webby award for the fastest
growing site on the entire internet and
it was a lot of it was driven by that iq
test and all the traffic that was
brought in
and um and that's when things took off
and we went from 1 million revenue to 4
to 16
and then by 2004 we were at
at a run rate of 25 million
and that's when
now getting to um to the answer that's
when we put ourselves in a position to
be lucky for two reasons one because we
had real revenue we were doing 25
million of revenue at that point on our
way to 40 million the next year and
number two because
a a friend of ours was also an hbs
classmate a year ahead of us had sold
his company his name's chris michael to
monster
about six months prior and andy mckelvey
the ceo of monster who basically
controlled monster he was chairman of
the board and and could do whatever he
wanted he um uh chris knew that we were
about to raise money at 100 million
dollar value evaluation from excel who's
now one of my main investors in branch
out and chris also told andy this is
happening and if you're interested in
these guys excel is going to want 5x the
return on their money therefore you're
going to have to buy them for 500
million dollars later mark the market
cap of monster was too small to support
a deal that big so andy said no no we
need to do this right now so we told
excel give us a week james and i flew to
to new york to meet with monster and it
was a very quick process because we had
real revenue and we already came vetted
by um by chris and um and then james and
i found ourselves in andy's office
and we we had gone in there you know
reminding ourselves we want a hundred
million dollars that's a goal we sat
down with andy and it was a three minute
conversation he sat down and said guys
i'd like to buy your company and i'd
like to pay 80 million
james and i looked at each other and
said we'd like 120 million andy who's a
75 year old billion multi-billionaire
sat back thought about it and then
said guys i'm going to offer you 100
million and that's it
and james and i at that point knew this
negotiation is over this is not going
any further
um james and i and our best poker faces
looked at each other
andy you have a deal and 100 million
deal was done what's that feel like to
hit a goal that you set out to do nine
years ago i mean
you get a what did you do you get a
little top hat and a monocle you know
what it it's
is that our matching outfit next time um
i doubt if you are so
you know what what's weird about when
you sell your company is that it's not
like you just won the super bowl it's
like three two one yeah you know it's
it's this process where we agreed to it
and then you go through like two or
three weeks of due diligence and then
the legal stuff and all that stuff and
then you get paid when everything you
know when all that's done and then you
know it hits your bank account and then
you kind of go to your co-founder hey we
did it but it doesn't have the same
thing like you just won the super bowl
like that moment but of course i mean it
felt sure it felt great and it allowed
me to um you know to do some nice stuff
for my family to do angel investing and
to have um
you know some security for my family so
it was kind of all right this is awesome
let's get back to work
yeah i mean we also had an urn out so we
just kept cranking away with a business
and um you know when someone offers you
that much
and um they ask you to stay on you know
it was the right thing to do for us to
stay on for another two years
all right do we have uh one more
question
i'd like to talk a little bit about
branch out a couple of years ago social
recruiting was very hot and you were
able to raise quite a nice amount of
money
uh
recently
most of the players have their own
challenges and not only in social
recruiting but all facebook-based
businesses maybe
how do you see this going forward and
with mobile and with facebook-based
businesses
sure so um yeah so facebook made some
major changes to the platform about a
year and a half ago
and um
you know
prior to that branch out was adding 400
000 new users a day with zero marketing
i mean that's a big number right so um
those were the fun days um of facebook
they made changes right before they went
public um to be able to better monetize
the the feed with ads instead of free
promotion for branch out and zynga and
all the other app developers so um you
know the lesson there is be careful when
you develop on another platform that you
don't control
so um you know
and you know in many good ways we were
able to do some wonderful things with
branch out and build a very big database
and raise money and do some awesome
things and helping people get back to
work and then in other ways when you
rely on another platform that is a risk
that can you know that can really hurt
your growth
and you we talked about this and uh so
when when facebook made a change
branched out kind of got screwed for a
minute and you had a great answer i was
like were you devastated how did you
feel and you told me something really
amazing which goes along exactly with
the title of this talk which is this
is hard um i mean
it'd be easy to be devastated and just
freak out be like i'm i'm screwed i've
raised 56 million dollars my business is
i'm i'm
i mean nobody nobody's gonna feel bad
for me or should feel bad for anyone i
mean it's um i don't i mean i i didn't
feel bad i mean you just react to it
right you you make changes
um
you've got to adjust and and you know
you don't go home and cry about it you
figure it out i mean inactivity leads to
to to doubt and fear
activity leads to
confidence and courage
and if you
you know
you've gotta you've gotta be active to
be courageous and um and we made changes
um based on you know the information we
had and move forward and you did not
dwell on it it was it was that was
amazing
of course we thought about okay what do
we do now um so you know we were um
pragmatic about it but um but you know
we're not gonna i mean nobody wants to
hear us crying or bitching i mean you
just move forward yeah i mean when you
told me this is part about being this is
part of being an entrepreneur like i
mean we called it this is hard this
this this session because it is hard and
that stuff's gonna happen um and things
that are you know worse can happen too
um you've got to know what you're
getting into being an entrepreneur
because it's not all about great
techcrunch stories and and and meeting
you know presidents and interesting
people it's um you know most of it is a
day-to-day grind and this stuff is going
to happen and if you don't have the
stomach to ride that roller coaster you
really shouldn't be an entrepreneur
and i tell people that to hopefully save
them heartache later
i love being an entrepreneur there's
nothing else i'd rather do i love it i
love the ecosystem i love working with
smart creative people that's why i do
this
but you also have to know especially as
a founder how much pressure is on you
you can never shut it off
you know you're always on you're always
pitching your company and bad stuff is
going to happen and i've had you know
the highest highs and lowest lows all in
the same day and this is you know one
example in a big way um of stuff that
happens as part of that journey
so we're uh we're about out of time but
is there anything that you'd like to
tell the crowd that you wish that you
would have
known or been told when you were
just getting just getting going
i mean the things that have helped me um
in my career from early days and these
are just general not necessarily as a as
a founder but you know i've tried to
work harder than everyone around me
i've tried to
say yes a lot
you know if someone gives you the
opportunity to do something say yes
whether it's a project at work
or it's a business dinner or a
networking event or whatever
say yes and just get out there and do
stuff and then you know i talked about
attitude earlier but having a good
attitude goes a long way not just as a
founder and kind of rolling with these
these punches but also early in your
career because you know people want to
mentor the smart people that have a good
attitude that are willing to work harder
than anyone else um you're going to
stand out you're going to get the best
projects
you're going to get mentored by the best
people so just i mean those three things
can take you pretty far
well before we wrap up um we do have um
a cool little surprise we've got i think
right now we should have one or two
school buses uh outside so um
once we wrap up here uh sales for
startup has been kind enough to provide
us with two buses that will be waiting
out waiting outside for us right now so
if you're interested in going to the
after party which is only about a mile
away
we can all get on that bus together and
head over there so please check out
sales for startups they're bennett and
the guys here are awesome they run a
bunch of sales workshops so we got that
going and i just want to thank you for
coming this has been a really badass and
thank you everyone for stopping by this
has been a really really really great
day thanks guys